sony logo alone takes 15 seconds then it
morphs into a 19 second Columbia logo I
don't even think the Columbia label
existed anymore point is 34 seconds for
two logos for the same company is too
much and everyone knows it in its
signature look I realize this is a
laid-back tropical paradise and
everything shouldn't this kid be
somewhat super biased I mean this is a
beach that has to be known for its short
population right no adults are even in
sight kids x-ray vision allows them to
see the floating helmet that's hidden by
a rocket this GoPro is perfectly edited
footage in order to properly freak this
kid out
come on moving her phone is clearly
visible right there using visual tricks
like this to try and make Instagram
cinematic Istanbul doing the pics even
though this picture says mom 1991
dumbass driver asks this dumbass
question Jesus crisis movie over apps
not so many getting hoarse yet that's
gringas she's not coming way too much of
this plot is relying on this stupid King
friend getting slammer Don tequila the
night before also why is Nancy figuring
this out now this is a secret King Beach
that's way the fuck out in the middle of
nowhere but she just planned on meeting
Ana out here at some point why not wait
on her and go together don't we left
back at the hotel there's it's not like
Don Julio and bad choices ladies and
gentlemen the screenwriter these text
messages are going through
instantaneously even though Nancy's out
in the heart of darkness and should have
very little reception
I am reliable movie glosses over the
ability of this driver to speak pretty
perfect English until it's convenient to
add a translation gag
what is this bitch call
not gonna tell me cool hey so how did
you ask for a ride to a beach you don't
know the name but did you say to this
guy back at the hotel to get him to take
you here with you not even knowing where
you were going this is the one hey how
many other secret beaches are there she
knew the beach by sight but not my name
and it was still able to describe it to
him to get her here even though she's
never been here
smoothie is playing with me hardcore
early on this girl simply has not enough
information about this place to get here
and also has too much information about
this place this is a shark attack movie
and I'm already angry not even 6 minutes
in did you spot eyes perfect and nothing
bad will ever happen here cut and print
you know there are a lot of things that
bother me about this movie but nothing
is worse than those stupid earrings that
somehow become important of a plot later
see I don't know we were going the same
way at least clothes life its Carlos a
professional driver or does he work at
the hotel and for some reason was
knocking off work at 1:30 p.m. or was he
just a random dude that Nancy hit up for
a secret be tried I mean I was in
medical school but we didn't have sense
it's a cheap excuse for expositional
dialogue on Nancy's medical background
is cheap how you gettin out of here over
okay either she's joking and she has no
plan for a ride out of here potentially
because she knows sharks will attack her
and change her plans where she actually
thinks uber will pick her up here which
makes her just stupid enough to maybe
deserve a good shark attack to snap her
back to reality Ellis is obviously
employed as a professional woodworker
oil changer metal collector and Terk
salesman we interrupt their short movie
to bring you an urban outfitters
commercial she labels the bag that has
some pink sunscreen it's a clear bag
with three containers that obviously
indicate their sunscreen dear moody you
cannot get me to fall for the standard
hot girl disrobing the hell leash also
given the way a half-naked Nancy's
working this bored and confused as to
whether I'm watching surf porn or actual
porn yep definitely only want to zip up
that wetsuit to maximum cleavage levels
it serves no other purpose in case
you're wondering yes the following 60
minutes will consist of lingering shots
of Blake's lively lady lumps damn this
wave is perfect storm levels of huge
after the super tepid looking beach we
first saw the director realizing how
thin the premise was for this movie
relied heavily on slow-motion to make
sure the screw was feature linked say
how many cuts do you think we need for
her diving into this wave and paddling
after is it 5 because it's 5 even if you
don't think it should be 5 of the very
few surfers that know about this secret
Mexican beach happens to also speak
perfect English you America
I'm sure surfers are a pretty chill
Bunch overall but Nancy's in the middle
of nowhere by herself out on open water
disclosing personal information to two
strange men hasn't she ever seen 48
hours this is like how all of them start
only once not a day I wanna tag it slow
it becomes an island for shouting I
think I'll be alright this is almost a
rivers roll credits mixed with the dun
dun dun punto de rigueur please skip
that wave she's surfing so how the hell
can they see what she's doing since that
wave should absolutely be blocking their
visas dude this is a big beach for only
three people but you got a surf you're
surfing right on top of Serena van der
Woodsen here ante wouldn't hang with the
guys before because she thought they
might be creepy but now that they've
seen each other's SERPs they're all
buddy-buddy
[Music]
this is what would happen if you scored
Blue Crush with darude-sandstorm this is
a borderline iconic shot and I'm tempted
to take a sin away but then I think
where are all the claims that were so
super gnarly like three seconds ago well
that was fun wasn't it
guess it's time to head back and grab
some margaritas with Anna who probably
has drunk off her hangover by this board
the director said hey let's have you
eaten the Apple after showing off your
badass surfing skills because apples a
portable food one might eat on the beach
and also we weren't sure how to make the
shark look like an asshole it didn't
have him attack you Nancy has her phone
pictures sorted too conveniently show us
the progression of her mother's story
holy this director has never seen an
extreme close-up that hasn't caused a
spontaneous erection
sir crop not only does Nancy get cell
reception on this incredibly remote
island paradise she can stream discount
FaceTime perfectly I mean look she's
only got two ping bars showing that mean
watch how you wind up on mantle great
okay short crop would be excellent at
cinema since that's what we fill crop
who do you want me to say say you're
coming back say you're not dropping out
of med school after all this time oh my
god this movie is heaping exposition
under this character that needs very
little you're a shark movie movie feel
free to shark at any time don't do that
don't make this about her what else
would it be about um I don't know sharks
you know there's a limited amount of
beach area here we're those assholes
with the GoPro go they're not out in the
water and it's clear from the shot that
no one else is overhearing the obvious
backstory conversation with pops it's
becoming more and more apparent that we
would have been having a much better
time watching a movie about Anna's
shenanigans on this trip hey let's go
ahead I'm gonna catch my last one main
character wants one last score cliche
one of many pseudo 10 fake outs that
occur within 15 minutes of this movie ah
sudden CGI Dalton hey it looks a hell of
a lot like a giant whale carcass gotta
go explore that seriously but presumably
they all been surfing next to this
extremely visible whale corpse for
several hours but she's just now
noticing it honestly can't tell at this
shot of a shark chasing her in the waves
she's surfing is cooler lame I'm gonna
send it just in case but I have a
sneaking suspicion that this shot is
actually cool shark is more interested
in being a mischievous dick than being
an actual predator I know it's the main
plot of the movie and all but Nancy
survives this okay she's just been
bitten and dragged under by the shark
but look at the amount of blood on
display here this is blood loss enough
to cause death and yet she pulls through
I mean this shots suggest she lost all
her blood and someone spilled Cheerwine
in the ocean by the gallon even though
who wound is still wounded the water
from absurdly red to perfectly clear in
just a few quick frames and that's why
you always leave a note dan this movies
done such a good job at establishing
position that I'm even more confused so
why nobody noticed the enormous whale
carcass right next to them while they
were surfing wow it's like everything
the surfer dude told her about earlier
is getting in on the action if only he'd
mentioned there are also sharks
I'll take things I did not need to see
for 800 Alex Nancy is spilling copious
amounts of blood into the water but is
only inches away from her yet this
dickhead shark who exploded a dead whale
to get to her is running an errand or
something while she stitches herself up
luckily Mexico has their own version of
a Bruce Almighty moon in order for this
scene to be properly lit yeah you're
gonna want to go ahead and just cut that
off hey sure Nancy always travels with
incredibly sharp jewelry for an occasion
just like this goddamn this movie's
cheeky gadget displayed cheekiness it's
like a hallmark movie with a real
Hollywood budget
Nancy perfectly sums up the last hour of
this movie also dear Hollywood we do not
need to see people puking to get the
point
gone Nancy's magic surfboards gonna stay
right in place throughout an entire tide
change
yeah well it's a movie and he's a shark
so yes I realize Nancy's desperate here
but what does she expect to happen if
she gets to the magic surfboard she was
on it when the shark first attacked so
it's clear mister shark don't give a
fuck about surfboards magic or not why
is Nancy still pouring blood when she's
in the water the wound was barely
bleeding a few minutes ago sure she's
using her leg more this is more blood
than when the folks of Amity were coming
for Jaws
he gravely injured Nancy once again I'll
swim the large aquatic predator to get
to safety
holder if the Sharks going to lose its
shark guard when it could spec too short
village yeah I'm starting to wonder if
this movie is just a chance to see how
many ways Blake Lively can painfully
exclaim sudden guy passed out or dead on
the beach cliche wait what Beach dude
happens to wake up just as she's
screaming at him though he will end up
being a drunk thief who won't help her
and this is just another red herring to
pad the runtime yeah he's pretty badly
injured but the bigger question is why
can't this game shark finish anyone off
this drunk mother or somehow wriggled
away and was able to drag the lower half
of his body to shore movie wants to make
me believe that this somehow Cynthia and
Seagal is actually Nancy spirit animal
oblivious surfer dudes that again missed
the giant king will corpse yesterday are
back again two hilariously walked past
the man corpse that's lying on the beach
torn in half Oh frog here I want these
dense motherfuckers to die so hard that
I actually hope the shark eats them in
slow motion even though it's obvious
it's coming shark jump scare still
deserves a sit
GoPro guy also has a magic sword that's
able to cause even more unnecessary jump
scares and yet the water level on this
rock Island has changed very little over
the last 20 hours or so
dickhead shark finally the science of
swim by to let us know he's still around
I mean thing's already eaten three
humans and most of a whale does it
really need any more food it's gonna
hard just for a second and then you're
going to be okay an 80 minute movie has
time for this 32 seconds from the whale
to the rock incredible disappearing
whale carcass comes back into play for
the final act even though we haven't
seen that person's it was blowed up by
mr. shark about 30 minutes ago
also the Sharks only been doing this
routine for a little while now since he
was previously swimming around the
entire cove hoping to jump scare people
to death might be presumptuous to assume
an accurate schedule with a small last
sample size
did he seriously just wait for her to
turn around holy
this shark loves drama nancy pass at the
time by watching some sick x-games
auditions in this angle the shark is
coming directly at the camera before
killing random surfer dude but the
camera somehow undamaged starting I
think this movie secretly just a long
commercial for GoPro let's go three
other people since I got here let the
cap into the GoPro it was recording
perfect video and was untouched by the
shark but when Nancy uses it the feed
looks like an old camcorder with a
malfunctioning tape dad I gotta get off
this rock stone there I want you to know
I'm gonna fight like she taught her this
moment is such a mixture of cheesy
cliches that it should be called a
cliche souffle
are you kidding me this is what the
director should have said to the
screenwriter when he first read this
scene
Nancy makes a broad assumption that the
shark doesn't like jellyfish because it
wasn't a fan of the core and decides the
best way to avoid certain shark death is
to swim through a massive probably also
deadly jellyfish the biggest sin here is
this plan ends up working even a little
after this attack shark once again
pieces out until the scripter question
to return where are you damn I guess
they used up the effects budget before
the final actions this shot looks so
terrible it could have been used in
sharknado I have no idea if a big shark
could actually eat an entire metal buoy
but if it can it shouldn't be
susceptible to a gentle tap on the nose
what having worked
whatever that shark in course the only
one that can rescue Nancy is her driver
from the beginning of the movie everyone
else on this Beach is a drunk thief or
an incompetent millennial none of these
dumbasses think to turn Nancy on her
side while she's aspirating on sea water
while Nancy leaves their hallucinating
Carlos does jack to help her out like
transporting her to safety or getting
her a bottle of water ready to get wet
dr. Adams thanks to her sisters over
emphasis on her new title we now know
that Nancy had time to fully recover
from her injuries reenroll in medical
school complete her coursework graduate
and reconciled with her family all
within a year
yes um it's dr. Adams now asshole
[Music]
let's go surfing come on everybody's
learning how the weather outside is
whether my god you know I don't speak
Spanish
[Music]
focus to you what you do with a
motorboat you play the motorboat you
float a boat inside of a bitch
Wickham you did to this buoy which I'm
gonna try this one - those aren't
bullies dad I got to get off this rocks
doing but I want you to know I'm gonna
fight for you the game um whoever can
topple the fastest out of these
jellyfish weird ruin screw rules you
can't touch the tentacles only the top
7s